Sorry about that.
Good evening all.
I trust you've had a fruitful day.
I don't say happy, of course, although I hope it has been happy.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambho Tassa
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambuddhasa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
By the way, I've softened the language of the Metta Sutta.
I think I got fed up with all these shoulds, like I think a lot of you might have done.
It's only a translation after all.
So I hope you like my rephrasing of it later on.
So yesterday we talked about friendship and there was this business of ready to die for a friend.
So this is something else which...
is also a brings up a different type of death so this is called the advice to chanda and on that occasion the venerable one they were staying in the bamboo grove which is the a very regular place at rajgir the capital near rajgir the capital of magadha which is on the kanjis there
And the Venerable Chanda was living with him on Vulture's Peak.
Vulture's Peak was where he gave many of his talks.
The Buddha gave many of his talks.
Now, on that occasion, the Venerable Chanda was afflicted, suffering and gravely ill. And when it was evening, the Venerable Sariputta rose from meditation, went to the Venerable Mahachandra and said to him, French Chandra, let's go and visit Chanda and ask about his illness.
And then after they do so, and after the exchange greetings with him, when the Curtis and Andy Bull talk was finished, they sat to one side and said, I hope you're getting well, friend Chanda, says Sariputta.
I hope you're comfortable.
I hope your painful feelings are subsiding and not increasing, and that they're subsiding, not that increase is apparent.
So I hope you're getting well, and I hope it's obvious to you you're getting well.
Venerable Buddha, I'm not getting well.
I'm not comfortable.
My painful feelings are increasing, not subsiding.
The increase and not their subsiding is apparent to me.
I shall use the knife.
So this is one way of saying he's going to commit suicide.
I have no desire to live.
Let the Venerable Channa not use the knife.
Let the Venerable Channa live.
We want the Venerable Channa to live.
If he lacks suitable food, I'll go in search of suitable food for him.
If he lacks suitable medicine, I'll go in search of suitable medicine for him.
If he lacks proper attendant, I will attend him.
Let the Venerable Channa not use the knife.
So here's Sariputta pleading with him.
Friend Channa, it is not that I do not have suitable food or a proper attendant, but rather...
that the teacher who is long worshipped by me with love, not without love, for it is proper for the disciple to worship the teacher with love and not without love.
Friends, Sariputta, remember this, the Bhikkhu Channa will use the knife blamelessly.
So in other words, it would be a dishonor to the teacher to do something which would disgrace him, to do something which he would definitely tell you not to do.
But Chanda says, no, I will commit suicide in a blameless way.
We would ask the Venerable Chanda certain questions.
By the way, the fact that he said blamelessly is suggesting he's fully liberated.
Because there is another occasion where an Arahant, who is also in great pain from illness, says to the Buddha, I'm going to take the knife.
That's how they would put it.
And the Buddha says, do as you see fit.
The Buddha wouldn't take moral decisions for other people.
Frank Chandler, do you regard the eye, eye consciousness and things cognizable through eye consciousness as mine, this I am, and this is myself?
And he goes through all the senses and the heart mind.
And of course, the question is, is there still any identity within you with the psychophysical organism?
And his reply is, I regard that the I and I consciousness, things cognizable through on all that are not mine, not I, not myself.
So he's saying that he is.
And then Sariputta says, what have you seen?
What have you directly known?
So he's questioning him now because he's not sure that this monk is actually fully liberated.
You can overestimate your attainments.
What have you seen?
What have you directly known by your direct experience?
This is the point you see.
And he replies, it is through seeing cessation, through directly knowing cessation in the eye, and so on and so forth.
So, in other words, it's the point where the whole of the psychophysical organism, as it were, drops away and you are left with the Buddha within, right?
That's what he's saying, cessation.
Now, when this was said, Mahaconda also doesn't believe that he's actually fully liberated.
so he says therefore uh french and now this this instruction of the blessed one is to be constantly given attention there is way there is wavering in one who is dependent there is no wavering in one who is independent when there is no wavering there is no tranquility there is tranquility when there is tranquility there's no bias no bias there's no coming and going
When there's no coming and going, there's no passing away and reappearing.
And where there's no passing away and reappearing, there is no more here, nor beyond, nor in between.
This is the end of suffering.
So you have to rely on the commentary which Bhikkhu Bodhi gives at the back of the book to understand this.
So he says wavering, so wavering, of course, is moving from desire and then not desire, falling into the wrong sort of desires and then coming out.
That's wavering, okay?
But somebody who's fully liberated doesn't waver.
There's no of that wrong desire left in them.
Now, when, of course, there's no wavering, there's absolute tranquility.
There's no restlessness in the system.
And when there's tranquility, that also means that there's no view or opinion of I'm right and everybody else is wrong.
There's no ego there.
There's no sense of pride.
Now, when there's no sense of pride and there's no self, then, of course, there's no coming and going.
That's just another way of saying rebirth, right?
Coming from one birth and going again.
And when there's no rebirth, there's no passing away and reappearing.
That's just another way of saying it.
And when there's no passing away and reappearing, then there is no here, no beyond or in between.
In other words, you're transcendent of all the phenomenal and physical world.
And that, of course, is the Buddha.
And this is the end of suffering.
Then when Venerable Sariputra and Venerable Chanda had advised this Venerable Chanda, thus they rose from their seats and went away.
Soon after they'd gone, the Venerable Chanda used the night.
then venerable sariputta went to the blessed one paying homage to him sat to one side venerable sir the venerable channel has used the knife what is his destination what is his future course so the buddha was able to see where people were born he that was one of his um clairvoyance abilities once he was liberated that he could actually see where people were moving from realm to realm and so on
sariputta didn't the bhikkhu chandra declare to you his blamelessness so in other words the buddha is saying well didn't he say he was blameless so he must be an arahat now uh there's a bit of confusion there because it's understood that uh in in the discourses that it was during the moment that he was dying when he realized what his rebirth would be
uh because of this act that he actually uh should we say liberated himself from that desire and became an arahat and then there's some some ill report about chanda so venerable sir there's a vagian village called pubajira and there the venerable channel had families that were friends families that were his intimate some families that were blameworthy in other words they're doing naughty things
and what it's there's a there's a suggestion that he was far too intimate with them that he hadn't actually let go of the household life of this of the sensual life uh then the buddha replies there are those families that were friends of bhikkhu channa sariputta families that were his intimates families that were blameworthy but i do not say that to this extent he was blameworthy
Sariputta, when one lays down his body and clings to a new body, that I say is blameworthy.
Now, in other words, if somebody kills themselves for wrong reasons, commits suicide for wrong reasons, then of course they will be reborn.
And that would be blameworthy.
But there was none of that in Bhikkhu Channa.
Bhikkhu Channa used the knife blamelessly.
This is what the Blessed One said and Venerable Sariputta was satisfied and delighted in the Blessed One's words.
So this brings up the whole discussion around suicide and whether there are any occasions when it would be right to take your own life.
As you know, Buddhist culture is not so hard on suicide in Christian and
the abrahamic religion culture of course you go to hell forever or worse but um suicide uh say in japan to say you know when you do something wrong to uh the um uh the samurai code uh you would of course you know put the knife put the sword into your stomach and draw it across that was seppuku in uh in times the the losing general would fall upon his sword
That was probably an easy way to go because the victorious general wouldn't treat him very well.
There is, of course, the women in Hinduism throwing themselves on the pyre of their husband as a manifestation of love.
I mean, that's what it's meant to be.
But it's also called sati, by the way.
And there's also, if you remember that, you might be old enough to remember the Vietnamese monk who set fire to himself during the Vietnamese war as a protest.
And that was quite remarkable.
You can probably see it still on YouTube, where the flames are engulfing and as his body leans to the left, his hand goes out ever so gently to right himself up.
And, of course, he eventually burns to death.
It's a remarkable thing.
So there's...
Yes, I've said that.
There was a case at the Vihara when I was there with my teacher, Dr. Reva Tadama.
And a man used to visit us who really had
constant desire to commit suicide.
And he used to carry a rope in the boot of his car, believe it or not.
Anyway, eventually he did.
And I asked my teacher, I said, Bhante, what happens to somebody who commits suicide?
Oh, he said, they'll keep doing it for about 100 lifetimes.
And I thought, well, that's a load of rubbish.
But actually, when I thought about it, I thought, well,
If a person has used suicide to escape something, to escape what is unwholesome, or to escape something that they can't handle, like shame, public shame or something like that, then, of course, it takes a lot of courage to kill yourself, I would say.
And that means a tremendous amount of will.
So there is within that person the habit that if I come across such and such an occasion, the habit will come up to escape it by way of death.
So I understood that maybe once somebody has committed suicide, that it might roll on for a few lifetimes.
But obviously here we have a case where, and we have another case too, where an Arahant actually commits suicide because the pain is unbearable.
So in those days they wouldn't have had palliatives or anything like that.
And it opens up the whole question about, you know, assisted dying and all that.
And it's a question fraught with all sorts of arguments and all sorts of stuff.
uh one hopes for oneself that one is never put in a position where you feel you have to you know bring your own life to an end it's not it's not the best way to go but taking taking you know this uh the buddhist stance that it's all to do with intention what why are you wanting to end your life you know
and there are certain illnesses which uh which even today they they don't have palliatives for which are just unbearable in their suffering and so one has to have a certain understanding about that and maybe that person in so we say relieving themselves of that pain actually uh find so find insight find insight so this is a case where that happens um
So it doesn't have this terrible thing about it, suicide, in Buddhist culture.
So anyway, some thoughts to go by.
If you go on to the Buddhist Journal, the Buddhist Ethical Journal, there's a big discussion there, especially with a man called Damien Keown, who's written an excellent book on Buddhist ethics.
So I think that's enough for the evening and we can begin our practice.